ich dich auf die gesamtlage blicken und
immer wieder haben wir die große
verantwortung
alles was wir in unserer macht haben zu
tun damit es keinen rückfall in eine
schwierigere phase gibt sondern dass wir
schritt für schritt vorankommen
guten abend willkommen zum zdf spezial
es ist eher ein vorsichtiges tasten als
ein radikaler kurswechsel aber es tut
sich was
mit strengen auflagen dürfen spielplätze
wieder öffnen auch museen und zoos und
auch gottesdienste dürfen wieder besucht
werden wie es mit schulen und kitas
weiter geht ist dagegen noch offen was
ist noch zumutbar was kann wann
gelockert werden
ob die fußball-bundesliga weiter machen
kann ob restaurants öffnen dürfen das
ist noch nicht entschieden
ein stück mehr normalität wäre das und
ein wirtschaftsfaktor ist es auch bis
die kugel wieder rollt wird es noch
dauern vor leeren rängen dann zunächst
aber geisterspiele sind ja sowieso
umstritten
damit funktioniert aber sogar dafür uns
fans nicht so gut es findet die
geisterspiele besser als überhaupt nicht
die politik beschließt nächste woche zu
beschließen wann und wie es weitergeht
mit der liga die politik muss die enkel
dickere die finale entscheidung treffen
wir als bundesligisten oder auch die dir
fällt wir können eigentlich nur
vorbereiten wirklich die den
maßnahmekatalog so gut wie möglich
umsetzen der deutsche profifußball
längst auch virus opfer fast 60.000
arbeitsplätze sind betroffen
die guten erlöse aus der letzten
spielzeit bereits jetzt unerreichbar
könnt ihr auf die idee kommen und zu
spielen und ein paar minuten später
denke ich habe meine güte wenn es
irgendwie geht mit einer tatsächlich
großen risikominimierung dann ist es
schon ganz okay
wann ist der richtige zeitpunkt und
unter welchen bedingungen nächste woche
mittwoch geht die debatte in die
verlängerung
das leib und seele ist eins von drei
restaurants die michael baumann in
münchen betreibt der wirt hatte auf
baldige lockerungen gehofft und ist
enttäuscht
es bleibt dabei kein gast darf sich
hinsetzen mit dem verkauf zum mitnehmen
kommt er gerade mal auf ein drittel vom
normalen umsatz für die drei betriebe
heißt 42 mitarbeiter in kurzarbeit
volle pachtzahlungen mit nebenkosten
momentan können wir uns nur mit kleinen
außer haus geschäften renovierungs und
putzarbeiten beschäftigen fast alle der
2,4 millionen beschäftigten im
gastgewerbe sind von den corona
beschränkungen betroffen zehn milliarden
euro weniger umsatz haben sie bislang
erwirtschaftet schätzt der deutsche
hotel und gaststättenverband über ein
ende des gastro locker und soll erst in
zwei wochen überhaupt verhandelt werden
ein konkretes datum ist nicht in sicht
anders wären wir sonst haben wir sehr
viele lokale eröffnet werden der wird
vom leib und seele kann noch ein paar
wochen durchhalten bundesweit schätzt
der verband dehoga könnte ohne
staatliche hilfen jedem dritten betrieb
im gastgewerbe die luft ausgehen
in berlin begrüße ich den
ministerpräsidenten von bayern guten
abend herr söder
guten abend
beim kampf gegen korona ist es jetzt wie
in der 80 minute eines fußballspiels
haben sie gesagt das klingt ja nach
baldigem abpfiff sind wir schon so weit
es klingt danach dass wir nicht das
spielfeld vorzeitig verlassen dürfen
wir haben deutschland bislang gut durch
diese krise gesteuert in europa gibt es
bewunderung für unseren kurs
jetzt darf es aber nicht um schlagen in
verwunderung dass wir zu schnell und
davon machen zu hoffen durch einen
überstürzten vorgehen vielleicht die
erfolge die wir haben wieder zu
gefährden
deswegen ja es wird weiter
erleichterungen geben aber ein leben mit
corona ist dem nicht das normale leben
was wir kennen wir brauchen bei der
umsicht und vorsicht
zu den schattenseiten gehört dass die
wirtschaft sich im sinkflug befindet
menschen verlieren ihre jobs fürchten um
ihre zukunft sind die drastischen
beschränkungen da nicht
unverhältnismäßig nein das glaube ich
nicht dass er international gesehen ist
die wirtschaft hier überall im sinkflug
und zwar mit viel dramatischeren
auswirkungen durch unser umsichtiges
vorgehen in deutschland können wir
wieder hochfahren und damit auch
insgesamt die wirtschaft stabilisieren
und durch die umfangreichen programm von
kurzarbeit bis bürgschaften
kreditprogramme die sind glaube ich
kommen wir auch besser aus der krise
heraus dass alle anderen wir kommen
nicht besser heraus als vorher aber
besser als die meisten anderen
und wenn wir es jetzt schaffen nach den
überbrückungs programmiert sind dann in
absehbarer zeit auch durch start
programme zu machen zum beispiel für die
automobilität beispielsweise in der
steuerpolitik durch investitionen die
wir tätigen auch bei unterstützung zu
bürgen bürger dann glaube ich können wir
am ende des jahres vielleicht wenn es
einen impfstoff gibt dann die bilanz
ziehen dass deutschland diesen
stresstest insgesamt gut überstanden hat
was in nordrhein westfalen schon wieder
erlaubt es muss es in bayern noch längst
nicht sein zum beispiel schule
wie sollen die bürger das nachvollziehen
und verstehen in der tat ist es eine
herausforderung
allerdings muss man eines sagen es hängt
halt auch ein bisschen vom
infektionsgeschehen hat das übrigens in
nordrhein-westfalen gar nicht so viel
anders ist als in bayern bewegen ist auf
einem ähnlich hohen niveau haben wir
beide große erfolge erzielt wie viele
andere bundesländer eben auch
deutschland insgesamt
bei der schule rate ich halt zu einem
wir müssen das sehr sensibel entwickeln
wir brauchen auch die notwendige
empathie ein überstürztes vorgehen kann
dazu führen dass wir dann wieder
zurückrudern müssen schulen wieder
schließen müssen wir müssen zwischen
land und den kommunen zwischen eltern
und lehrerschaft und vor allem für die
schüler eine verlässliche eine
kontinuierliche basis gewährleisten so
ist jetzt mein name nach gesichert dass
zum beispiel ein abitur gut gesteigert
werden kann verlässlich gestaltet werden
kann kein durchschnitts oder not abs und
es muss mit stück für stück für die
gesamte schulfamilie und 14 kinder
weiter entwickeln
es ist glaube ich auch das schwierigste
bereich aber regionale unterschiede gab
es bei schule immer und die waren auch
bleiben aber wir müssen den rahmen
setzen
er muss gleich bleiben die ferienzeit
rückt näher und so unterschiedlich wie
österreich das deutliche lockerung
beschlossen hat und deutschland in der
korona krise handeln wird es da
wechselseitige urlaube gegen können
zunächst in österreich ist uns einfach
zwei wochen ungefähr voraus das heißt so
unterschiedlich ist es ganz nett
es muss am ende beurteilt werden am ende
muss beurteilt werden wo man reisen
erlaubt es oder nicht aber ich sage
einmal für all diejenigen die sich
österreich als urlaubsort vorstellen
können kann ich dann einfach nur sagen
bayern ist da genauso schön also wer
österreich chinesen will der kann das
auch in bayern tun es ist nicht weit
entfernt und man kann mit gutem gewissen
entfernen
also da vielen dank für das gespräch wer
lockert wann und wie viel mit bangem
blick auf die zahlen müssen virologen
ihre empfehlungen und politiker ihre
strategien immer wieder anpassen
das virus ist neuartig dazulernen kann
man jeden tag der umgang mit corona aber
ist auch hochpolitisch und die zeit der
ganz großen gemeinsamkeit alle
versammeln sich hinter der regierung ist
längst vorbei andreas künast aus berlin
es kommt nicht oft vor dass die chefin
der bundesregierung den chef oder die
chefin einer landesregierung kritisiert
merkel sagt nicht den namen und auch
nicht das bundesland merkel sagt dass
ihr die umsetzung der bund länder
beschlüsse sorgen macht sie wirkt auf
mich in teilen wird
sie wirkt auf mich in teilen sehr forsch
um nicht zu sagen zuvor zu den dränglern
die merkel sorgen bereiten gehört nicht
nur nrw-ministerpräsident laschet die
wirtschaft will hochfahrend der fußball
macht druck die korona opposition wächst
außerhalb des parlaments und drinnen
es müsste viel schneller und wäre auch
viel schneller möglich eine öffnung wäre
ein hygiene konzept habt wie die
bundesliga der sollte öffnen können den
laden oder das restaurant
es geht nicht um weniger
gesundheitsschutz aber wir können das
inzwischen intelligenter machen als in
den letzten wochen
die regierung lässt zwar spielplätze
museen und gottesdienste öffnen aber
restaurants kinos und
veranstaltungshallen zu es ist der
versuch eines mittelweg zwischen den
dränglern und den bremsern vor allem
bayerns ministerpräsident sünder bremst
unterstützt von bekannten theologen von
funktionären aus dem gesundheitssystem
von der spd und von den grünen
ich stimme total zu dass wir jetzt dafür
sorgen müssen gemeinsam in unserem land
dass vorsicht geboten ist es geht hier
um die frage ob dem menschenleben
schützen können ja oder nein
bremser gegen drängler der streit wird
heftig manchmal hysterisch geführt muss
man schon sorgen haben um unser land
nein habe ich nicht sondern ich finde
eine sehr schöne entwicklung dass man
das pro und contra diskutiert das gehört
zu einer offenen gesellschaft darin
unterscheiden wir uns von anderen von
totalitären gesellschaften der speziell
deutsche weg durch die krise wird vom
bund bestimmt und von den ländern und
vom ewigen streit zwischen ihnen ob der
weg richtig ist
der nordrhein-westfälische
ministerpräsident armin laschet ist uns
jetzt aus düsseldorf zugeschaltet guten
abend guten abend herr fornoff
die beschlüsse von heute zeigen ein eher
vorsichtiges öffnen hätten sie sich mehr
lockerungen gewünscht naja das war für
den heutigen tag auch so besprochen weil
wir gesagt haben wir wollen erst einmal
sehen wie die öffnungen vom letzten mal
also die geschäftseröffnungen gewirkt
haben auf die infektionszahlen insofern
haben wir heute die
religionsgemeinschaften denen ermöglicht
wieder ihre gottesdienste zu halten
wir haben die zoologischen gärten die
botanischen gärten die spielplätze
wieder in den blick genommen aber die
eigentlichen entscheidungen sollen am 6
mai fallen und eines ist wichtig wir
haben auch gesagt wir können auch
regional unterschiedlich entscheiden
in nordrhein westfalen sind
beispielsweise heute diese erwehrte also
die von der helmholtz initiative
gefundenen kriterien bei 0,448 das ist
der zweitbeste wert in deutschland und
da kann man natürlich dann auch sagen
können wir nicht andere belastungen die
im moment auf den menschen lasten und
die auch schäden anrichten verändern das
werden wir am 6 mai erörtern
in ihrem bundesland haben ja schulen
wieder geöffnet die offenbar schlecht
darauf vorbereitet waren sind sie da zu
weit vorgeprescht
nein die schulen sind ja in ganz
deutschland geöffnet
in der letzten woche haben gleich sechs
bundesländer abiturprüfung geschrieben
und auch bei uns hat das in den schulen
sehr gut funktioniert ich glaube gerade
diese schulfrage ist eine die man
möglichst im konsens in deutschland
entscheiden sollte deshalb passiert auch
das am 6
und man muss wenn man noch mal an ihren
bericht in der heute sendung gerade
erinnern darf eben immer abwägen
bei kindeswohlgefährdungen erleben wir
im moment dass wenn kinder nicht mehr
zum arzt gehen nicht mehr in die kita
gehen und nicht mehr in die schule gehen
niemand mehr feststellt
findet denn eine kindeswohlgefährdung
stadt und das müssen wir in unser kalkül
immer mit abwägen mit einbeziehen
genauso wie wir die arbeitslosenzahlen
vom heutigen tag zehn millionen menschen
in kurzarbeit
auch das kann gesundheitliche schäden
beim menschen verursachen und dieser
abwägungsprozess der ist manchmal
schwierig aber dem müssen wir uns tag
für tag unterziehen denn wir schränken
immerhin grundrechte ein
und da muss man sich immer genau
überlegen wie lange kann man bestimmte
dinge geschlossen halten
der bundeswirtschaftsminister spricht ja
bereits von der schwersten rezession in
der geschichte der bundesrepublik ist
das nicht ein zu hoher preis und wie
lang kann man denn zahlen
das ist ein sehr hoher preis über den
wir in den letzten wochen viel zu wenig
gesprochen haben
wenn millionen menschen in
arbeitslosigkeit hineinrutschen werden
auch den sozialen sicherungssystemen in
der zukunft gelder fehlen
wir gehen da in eine große krise hinein
und deshalb ist die abwägung immer sehr
wichtig der gesundheitsschutz wir wollen
verhindern dass es erneut zu einem
großen ausbruch kommt wir wollen alles
tun dass es nicht zu einer zweiten welle
kommt wir wollen durch die
gesundheitsämter verfolgen wo denn die
infektionsketten sind vielleicht
demnächst auch mit einer app an der die
bundesregierung arbeitet wir müssen uns
schützen wir müssen hygienemaßnahmen
haben alles das gilt weiter aber wir
müssen auch sehen wie wir menschen
wieder in arbeit bringen so behutsam so
tastend so vorsichtig ist irgend möglich
ist aber wir müssen diese perspektive im
blick haben und das ist das was wir beim
nächsten mal intensiver erörtern werden
als im heutigen tag herr laschet vielen
dank für das gespräch
bitteschön die politik tastet sich durch
die krise die zahlen und den ratschlag
der virologen immer im blick der ganz
große befreiungsschlag war das heute
nicht konnte es wohl auch nicht sein
zu groß ist die sorge dass
die zahl der infektionen explodieren
könnte und eine zweite welle noch
schwerer zu beherrschen wäre als die
erste das war unser zdf spezial mehr
informationen jederzeit auf zdf heute
vielen dank für ihr interesse hier geht
es gleich weiter mit notruf hafenkante
einen schönen abend
tschüss wird immer mit dem thema die
politik macht auf die unsicherheit mit
familienministerin franziska giffey dem
virologen jonas schmidt-chanasit und dem
fdp vorsitzenden christian lindner 2